bienvenue dans cette émission qui fait
partie de notre série consacrée aux 40
ans de 50 ans en Yvelines on a parlé des
Haïtiens du tissu économique de
l'implantation des entreprises c'est un
peu le même sujet que nous allons
aborder aujourd'hui mais d'une façon un
peu différente d'une façon peut-être un
peu plus humaine puisque c'est de
l'emploi qu'il va s'agir pour en parler
José Manuel Rodriguez bonjour vous êtes
le directeur du Pôle emploi de Trappes
Christine vilain bonjour vous êtes
vice-présidente de la Commission emploi
prévention insertion et chargée de la
politique de la ville
François cemec vous êtes directeur de la
Mission Locale de 50 ans
et Pierre valse vous êtes le responsable
financier de l'école de la deuxième
chance des Yvelines bonjour c'est cela
oui alors on va tout de suite commencer
il y a trois parties dans cette émission
par les premières années
alors Christine Villain on va pas parler
de l'économie de comment on fait venir
les entreprises on en a déjà parlé ici
bien que c'est important pour l'emploie
il faut quand même attirer des
entreprises mais vous avez déjà quelque
chose qui existe dans la de la création
de la ville nouvelle c'est quand même
tout ce qui se passe à Trappes qui est
quand même un secteur industriel oui la
vie nouvelle a failli s'appeler trappe
en Yvelines et non pas 50 ans en
Yvelines parce qu'au départ c'est la
zone industrielle de Trappes qui avait
été mise en place créé par les élus de
l'époque qui a servi d'implantation
principale pour démarrer l'agglomération
nouvelle il y avait une tradition
industrielle alors une tradition
industrielle à la fois à travers la SNCF
avec l'historique du triage et puis
toute l'implantation de la zone
industrielle qui s'appelle maintenant
zone industrielle trap Élancourt tout le
long de la voie de chemin de fer mais
alors l'idée pour faire venir des
habitants il faut proposer des emplois
il faut les emplois ils peuvent pas
rester quatre après évidemment il faut
il faut qu'il y en ait un peu dans tout
le territoire au fur et à mesure les
équilibres ont fait que chaque commune a
petit à petit lancer des zones
industrielles des zones d'implantation
artisanales avec le PA à l'époque qui
s'occupait aussi de ces implantations et
le fait de voilà comment parce que la
création de tissus urbains vous êtes
responsable politique de la ville dont
on parlera des années plus proche tout à
l'heure mais il faut créer quand même
cette ville qui n'existe pas donc
l'emploi est un facteur important pour
créer ça oui parce que mais en fait
cette ville elle a commencé à l'ouest là
où il y avait l'emploi c'est-à-dire que
on a commencé par l'emploi et ensuite on
a vu Élancourt s'agrandir trap
s'agrandir avant qu'on passe à l'Est
mais elle s'est d'abord implantée sur
l'ouest là où était les premiers emplois
franchement je mec alors la mission que
vous dirigez la mission locale 50 ans en
Yvelines c'est une structure il en
existe d'autres dans le tour tout le
territoire mais à quoi elle correspond à
quoi est-elle à quoi sert-elle donc les
missions lesquelles il en existe 470 470
ça bouge un petit peu il y a des
regroupements des fusions enfin au
niveau national tout le territoire est
ouvert habituellement ce sont des
structures qui ont un statut associatif
et qui sont créés à l'initiative de
l'état de la région et des collectivités
locales c'était le choix qui avait été
fait au départ c'est que le projet
devait être porté par les collectivités
locales
l'objectif n'est pas de créer une grande
structure unique nationale qui aurait
des déclinaisons locales mais au
contraire localement qui est une volonté
politique de créer des structures pour
tenir compte des spécificités locales
que rencontrent les jeunes en matière
d'insertion puisque les missions locales
s'adresse
qui ont quitté le système scolaire et on
les accompagne dans leur démarche
d'insertion sociale et profession
personnel ces difficultés elles sont pas
du tout les mêmes ne serait si on prend
les Yvelines à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et dans le nord des Yvelines ou dans
certaines communes du sud de Yvelines
très très rurales les difficultés
d'énormes différences qu'est-ce qui a
été justement si on prend
l'établissement public le syndicat
d'agglomération quel a été sa politique
en matière d'emploi
la politique la politique en matière
d'emplois a toujours été un de
développer de l'emploi sur le territoire
en essayant que cet emploi soit adapté
aux populations locales mais on sait
quand même qu'à l'heure actuelle il y a
beaucoup de gens qui vont travailler à
l'extérieur et beaucoup de gens de
l'extérieur qui viennent travailler à 50
ans donc il y a beaucoup d'emplois à
Saint-Quentin mais il y a aussi des
publics à Saint-Quentin qui ne trouvent
pas en fonction de leur qualifications
c'est quelque chose qu'on pourrait
régler ou c'est difficile on a 50 ans de
l'emploi très qualifié mais on a aussi
des populations avec des niveaux de
qualification plus bas et là c'est de
l'emploi qui manque sur ce territoire
je suis manuel Rodriguez vous êtes donc
Pôle emploi de Trappes il y a des
problèmes d'emploi spécifique il y a une
adéquation comme il veut dire d'un
vilain entre les offres d'emploi des
entreprises et la main d'oeuvre
disponible aujourd'hui sur le territoire
de la Communauté d'Agglomération 51%
des presque 5000 demandeurs d'emploi
inscrit sur le territoire ont des
niveaux inférieurs au cap et équivalent
au Cap alors que par ailleurs des offres
d'emploi qui aujourd'hui ont en cours
c'est la proportion est quasiment
inverse donc on voit bien qu'on a un
vrai souci d'adéquation sur des postes
d'ingénierie sur des postes de recherche
et développement on a des on a des
difficultés aujourd'hui à trouver des
ressources sur le territoire quelles
sont les emplois pour vous demander
alors
il y a une tradition ça doit être très
divers évidemment mais est-ce qu'on peut
faire des catégories
on est aujourd'hui sur un territoire qui
traditionnellement travaille avec le
service du transport et la logistique on
voit bien qu'historiquement il y a un
lien avec la SNCF le premier service qui
sont qui sont alentours mais aujourd'hui
donc pour pour faire un bon dans le dans
le présent
les systèmes de vente par correspondance
font en sorte que on a plusieurs
plateformes logistiques qui font
qu'aujourd'hui les métiers du les
métiers de l'expédition les métiers de
du transport sont des métiers qui sont
aujourd'hui demander l'aide à la
personne parce que concrètement
aujourd'hui c'est un essor qui duquel la
communauté d'agglomération n'est pas
n'est pas exemple aujourd'hui on a
aujourd'hui des populations qui ont
aussi besoin d'être aidés dans leur
gestion soit des personnes âgées soit
des personnes dépendantes et puis
ensuite tout ce qui est l'hôtellerie
restauration parce qu'il ne faut pas
oublier que Ben nous sommes un
territoire où il y a des gens qui
travaillent et qui se restaure et que il
y a un tissu important de d'organes
d'établissements hôteliers et de
restauration alors on a déjà abordé un
peu les questions qui se posent
aujourd'hui on va y revenir tout à
l'heure je vous propose de regarder le
bord un sujet consacré à une population
qui est malheureusement sujette au
chômage ce sont les quinquas
2350 km à vélo de Narbonne à Paris pour
interpeller l'opinion publique sur les
difficultés d'emploi des Quincas
Eric Fournier 46 ans informaticien au
chômage depuis deux ans est arrivé à
Montigny Vendredi 21 Septembre au terme
de 40 jours de voyage la dernière étape
de son périple avant l'Elysée où il
devait remettre un dossier au président
un énorme ras-le-bol parce qu'en fait
dans ma région j'avais pas suffisamment
d'offres d'emploi et et devant mes
ordinaires les ordinateurs de la NPE
j'ai craqué je me suis dit bon c'est pas
possible si je reste comme ça à chercher
un travail sans le trouver je vais dans
5 ans 10 ans être dans la même situation
des milliers de personnes aujourd'hui
envoient des CV tous les jours non pas
de réponse et aujourd'hui donc ça les a
conduits dans une détresse qui s'allonge
chaque jour et bien non moi je me suis
dit j'ai la force j'ai la possibilité de
d'agir c'est le moment je pars je me
mets en action cette exclusion des plus
de 50 ans du monde du travail coûterait
à la France plus de 10 milliards d'euros
par an après le Conseil d'analyse
économique c'est à Montigny que ce sont
tenues les premières rencontres
nationales avec un cas c'était en 2003
depuis la situation des seniors dans le
monde du travail a peu évoluer l'âge
reste le premier facteur de
discrimination à l'embauche et les plus
de 50 ans sont la première cible des
restructurations
c'est bien
José Manuel Rodriguez c'est encore un
des secteurs de la population qui est le
plus sujet au chômage c'est un secteur
qui représente 20 % de la demande
globale sur le territoire de la
Communauté d'Agglomération c'est un
secteur qui
pour lequel aujourd'hui bon c'est un
public qui est sur les Yvelines
traditionnellement un public en
difficulté parce que la structure des
emplois qui sont proposés fait que
aujourd'hui
il y a une idée d'équation entre les
compétences qui sont aujourd'hui
disponibles et puisque redemment des
entreprises avec plus de flexibilité
alors on est dans la perception des
entreprises à nous de la faire changer
autant que possible lorsqu'on les a en
face on leur explique elle est
dispositifs qui existent il y a des
dispositifs tels que les contrats aidés
il y a des actions de formation qui sont
envisagées mais aujourd'hui on est face
à quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de la
défiance plutôt de la part des
entreprises vers ses publics dont on
dont on imagine dont on perçoit qu'ils
peuvent être moins malléables donc on
imagine que leur demande de rémunération
va être plus élevée que si on prenait
des jeunes peut-être avec moins
d'expérience les perspectives là-dessus
on va attendre un peu ce que ce que les
mesures qui sont prononcées vont pouvoir
nous permettre d'agir en étant sur le
contrat de génération dont j'entendais
ce matin qui serait à l'oeuvre en 2013
bon il faut nous outiller parce que
derrière effectivement on est en
situation de ne pas promouvoir davantage
ces populations là qui souffrent
effectivement d'un Doom le mouvement un
mouvement de démotivation on a bien vu
dans le dans le verre donc il y a
quelque chose
et d'un autre côté de faire de
l'attractivité de ces publics auprès des
entreprises ou concrètement il y a
quelque chose de l'ordre de la
transmission quelque chose de l'ordre de
la transmission des savoir-faire et des
valeurs qu'il faut réinterroger dans
l'entreprise Christine vilain est-ce que
ça puisque vous êtes en charge de la
politique de la ville est-ce que le
problème du chômage du sous-emploi
pousse des problèmes à la politique de
la ville oui parce que essentiellement
on s'aperçoit quelle que soit la tranche
d'âge que ce quelque chose le problème
de chômage c'est le problème de
qualification au niveau de qualification
et on se retrouve avec les populations
qui habitent dans les dans les quartiers
où les de la ville nouvelle qui sont
actuellement rénovation urbaine ça veut
dire que derrière il y a tout
l'accompagnement humain qui doit se
faire c'est-à-dire que on peut pas se
contenter se contenter de rénovation
urbaine il faut aussi travailler toutes
ces questions là et c'est pour ça que la
communauté d'agglomération a mis depuis
quelques années des outils en place il y
a la mission locale mais il y avait le
plan local d'insertion par l'emploi qui
permet à des gens de se reconstruire
dans un parcours et de retourner vers
l'emploi quand souvent ils en ont été
absents pendant pendant très longtemps
c'est la création de la deuxième chance
pour les plus jeunes sans niveau de
qualification 18-25 mais qu'on vit
vraiment de retourner vers l'emploi et
de se redonner le mal de de retrouver un
niveau suffisant pour rentrer en
formation professionnelle ou pour aller
directement vers l'emploi disons qu'on a
on a nous sur le territoire dans le
cadre de la politique de la ville
essayer de créer ces outils structurants
à disposition de ces publics pour
redonner plus que les coups de pouce les
moyens de repartir dire valse alors
justement la création de cette école de
deuxième chose les écoles de la deuxième
chose elle se crée en gros dans les
années 90 en France en tout cas celle de
celle de Saint-Quentin a été créée en
2007 la première effectivement a été
créée à Marseille une dizaine d'années
auparavant
et puis depuis
soit posé du gouvernement ça a été une
véritable explosion aujourd'hui nous
sommes à plus de 100 écoles de la
deuxième fois deuxième chance sur
l'ensemble de la France et
tout cela pour accueillir de l'ordre de
12000 stagiaires cette année alors à
quoi correspond ces écoles quel est leur
but que leur fonctionnement aussi que
est-ce que c'est des initiatives privées
est-ce que c'est une école de la
deuxième chance ne peut exister que
dans le biais à la base une nouveauté
politique
effectivement il faut que ce soit les
les collectivités locales qui soient
porteur sous un porteuse de ce projet
pardon et qui effectivement derrière
avec le soutien de la Région du
Département de l'État tous ensemble
mettent en mettre leurs efforts pour
pouvoir arriver à cette à cette création
et proposer ainsi aux jeunes du
territoire une alternative qui
permettent à ceux qui ont la motivation
nécessaire de revenir
vers un parcours plus classique tel que
nous le connaissons tous aujourd'hui ici
vers un parcours vers l'emploi qui soit
directement vers l'emploi ou qu'il soit
d'abord par une étape intermédiaire qui
est celle de la formation qualifiante
est-ce qu'il y a des liens justement
entre le Pôle Emploi l'école de la
deuxième chose l'émission parce que
voilà vous travaillez tous un peu dans
le même dans le même sens parce que sur
les écoles de la deuxième chance le lien
c'est l'entreprise c'est à dire que on
travaille aussi avec la Chambre de
commerce avec la présence d'entreprise
au niveau du conseil d'administration
avec un travail quotidien des équipes de
l'ODC avec les entreprises du territoire
là c'est vraiment le lien qui est le
plus important parce que
ils ont besoin de stage ils ont besoin
qu'on leur fasse connaître l'entreprise
et ils ont besoin que derrière
on leur fournisse des contrats de
travail par exemple la mission locale et
l'écologie ils ont besoin que l'ensemble
des
partenaires du territoire travail dans
la même direction pour eux et c'est pour
ça que que la communauté d'agglomération
ou la Mission Locale
ces deux organismes font partie des
administrateurs de l'école de la
deuxième chance des Yvelines
alors Pôle Emploi ça vous arrive par
exemple d'envoyer des des jeunes gens
vers l'école de la deuxième chance
forcément c'est même plus que ça
ça fait partie de la palette d'offre de
formation qu'on peut proposer aux jeunes
donc elle intervient sur un créneau bien
particulier je pense que elle remplit
très bien sa fonction il y a des raisons
pour cela et là
et donc je pense que sur l'école de la
même chose de trappe on doit représenter
plus de la moitié des orientations en
sachant que c'est un dispositif qui est
aussi en accès libre déjà n'ont pas il y
a des objectifs ou des chaînes doivent
être suivies par la Mission Locale pour
pouvoir être orienté là ils peuvent y
aller directement
l'objectif c'est effectivement que les
écrits vilain de les présenter à des
entreprises sur des offres d'emploi
existantes ce sur quoi il faut qu'on
s'orient davantage c'est être plus sur
des actions menées sur des cordes de
jeunes qui sortent des écoles de manière
optimisée aussi leur présentation auprès
des entreprises et ça c'est quelque
chose sur lequel il faut qu'on travaille
encore sur l'année 2012 et 2013 pour y
parvenir assez rapidement je vous ai pas
demandé le pour
que on n'a pas de baisse significatif il
y a une période où effectivement les
entrées au chômage ont commencé à être
un peu plus faibles ça a été le cas sur
le début de l'année dernière mais depuis
les augmentations sont assez régulières
et pour faire un focus particulier sur
les jeunes dont on parlait c'est la
seule population dont le chômage baisse
sur le territoire de la Communauté
d'Agglomération comment on explique
c'est plutôt bons résultats c'est on
peut dire qu'on a des bons résultats
parce que on a un bon niveau de création
d'emplois et d'implantation ceci dit ben
voilà il faut modérer ces chiffres parce
que on monte à 12 attrapes
des réalités
il y a des disparités il y a des
quartiers il y a des zones beaucoup plus
touchées même si 12% par rapport à des
quartiers qui sont
mais voilà une commune où il y a 12% de
chômeurs on peut pas s'en satisfaire et
forcément si on a la richesse des
emplois si on a un taux de chômage qui
est relativement bas par rapport à ce
qu'on peut voir ailleurs bah
profitons-en pour aider ceux qui ont
besoin d'être aidés est-ce que c'est pas
assez
parlant d'ailleurs parler de trap à 12%
qui était au fond la ville industrielle
de la
désindustrialisations françaises enfin
c'est pas un des phénomènes oui les
conséquences de ça je pense que c'est
aussi un phénomène de relégation de
certaines populations et que on peut pas
enfin c'est la ville nouvelle a les
moyens de d'aller vers ces populations
de faire ce travail et vraiment il doit
être fait alors il y a un moyen de
trouver parfois des emplois parfois
c'est un parcours du combattant mais
pour y remédier certaines villes
organisent des ce qu'on appelle des jobs
dating et je vous propose de regarder
des sujets qui consacrés justement ce
concept
dans le cadre de la Semaine de l'emploi
qui se tient jusqu'au 17 février 2012 à
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines l'Espace
Emploi d'Élancourt organisait ce lundi
un forum de speed jogging au prisme une
dizaine d'employeurs des agences
d'intérim pour la plupart étaient
présents
quand même les repérages parce que les
employeurs ont donc comme c'est des
sociétés d'intérim ont des portefeuilles
d'employeurs aussi bien en intérim camp
CDD CDI puisqu'ils peuvent recruter de
cette façon aussi et l'intérêt c'est
tout de suite de susciter et de
rapprocher l'offre et la demande lors de
ce forum le principe du speed dating est
ici repris et adapté pour les employeurs
les candidats passent les uns après les
autres et on diminue pour convaincre la
communication de l'événement a bien
fonctionné puisqu'à 16 heures une
centaine de participants avaient déjà
défilé sur les stands
les trucs assez rapides pour pour
rencontrer l'hameçon et là j'ai vu speed
jobbing j'ai fait a pour trouver du
travail assez rapidement bah ouais ça
peut être sympa c'est une façon une
bonne façon à mon avis de rencontrer les
employeurs
et d'avoir un copier contact avec des
employeurs en plus des agences d'intérim
quelques entreprises étaient là aussi la
poste par exemple était venue proposer
des postes de facteurs dans le cadre de
la convention signé avec Pôle emploi et
la préfecture des Yvelines ça
m'intéresse parce que comme j'ai
beaucoup de candidats qui viennent ici
ça me permet de voir un peu de temps
beaucoup de candidatures et puis
d'orienter les gens que je vois vers le
métier que moi je cherche à recruter ou
si c'est pas le cas je peux vite leur
dire que c'est pas c'est pas la cible la
Semaine de l'emploi se poursuit jusqu'au
17 février dans toute l'agglomération
prochain rendez-vous mercredi 15 février
pour un forum de recrutement à Skywest
dernière partie de cette émission
Christine vilain la Maison de l'Emploi
évidemment joue un rôle essentiel et
bien la Maison de l'Emploi commence à
prendre ses marques sur le territoire et
c'est vrai qu'elle travaille à l'heure
actuelle va en lien complet avec Pôle
Emploi bien sûr avec la directe et
l'État
on était ce matin justement ensemble à
l'assemblée générale de ces maisons de
l'emploi et c'est vrai que on est en
train de tracer des axes de travail pour
pour l'avenir en particulier à travers
une étude sur le développement social et
solidaire
de la communauté d'agglomération
et des axes de travail sur comment
mettre le en place des recrutements
quand une entreprise s'installe sur le
territoire comment faire circuler
l'information et comment faire en sorte
qu'on trouve sur le territoire les
formations adéquates si nécessaire pour
les entreprises qui s'installent est-ce
que c'est un rapport de la Cité des
métiers alors la Cité des Métiers elle
est au coeur elle est dans la maison de
l'emploi et cette cité des métiers
commence elle aussi à trouver son public
elle a trouvé tous les partenaires qui
travaillent la Mission Locale entre
autres par exemple vient faire des
permanences dans cette société des
métiers à l'heure actuelle on a un
public qui est localement important et
on commence à aller aux quatre coins du
département à être connu et les gens
viennent dans cette cité des métiers
pour trouver de l'information sur la
formation sur les parcours
professionnels sur le choix de son
métier pierre valse est-ce qu'il y a des
projets de l'école de la deuxième France
des projets nouveaux des projets
nouveaux pas actuellement puisqu'en fait
dans le cadre des relations qui nous qui
nous avons utilisé avec la région le
projet pour l'école de la deuxième
chance des Yvelines était de pouvoir
accueillir 3 ans stagiaires sur trois
sites donc aujourd'hui
ces choses faites l'objectif c'est de
organisé vraiment le dispositif donc sur
trap ça fait 5 ans que l'école a été
créé donc c'est vrai que maintenant
l'école de la deuxième champ des
Yvelines ici sur Saint-Quentin fait
vraiment partie du paysage
l'école de la deuxième chance sur le
site des Mureaux sur le site des
manteaux et un petit peu plus jeune donc
vraiment le projet pour nous c'est de
vraiment de pérenniser le dispositif sur
l'ensemble du département alors je vous
propose de regarder un sujet ce qui
évidemment l'emploi c'est aussi la
formation
sur sur une plateforme anti décrochage
qui a été mise en place dans passé au
concerne pas directement ça a été mis en
place par l'Éducation nationale mais
c'est vrai que s'il y a une bonne
formation ça garantit souvent des
emplois sujet donc sur cette plateforme
anti décrochage
selon l'éducation nationale chaque année
en France 140 000 jeunes sortent du
circuit scolaire sans diplôme entre
septembre 2010 et mars 2011 l'inspection
académique a recensé dans les Yvelines
plus de 2300 décrocheurs des jeunes HD
de 16 à 20 ans inconnus des services
d'émission locale d'où l'idée de créer
des plateformes anti décrochage ou
plateforme rebond afin d'identifier ces
jeunes au plus tôt grâce à un système
interministériel d'information géré par
un outil informatique appelé Rio exemple
tout bête un CFA d'un côté un
établissement scolaire de l'autre le CFA
c'est qu'il a perdu ses lèvres il était
pas présenté l'établissement l'apotêtre
ou ne l'a pas on croise des listes et
puis il y a un individu qui n'apparaît
plus nulle part c'est celui-là qu'il
faut aller chercher pour lui proposer
une solution pour être reprise en compte
par le dispositif le jeune doit répondre
à certains critères à avoir été
scolarisés l'année précédente ne pas
avoir obtenu le diplôme de son cursus
avoir 16 ans révolu et ne pas être
scolarisé ou inscrit en apprentissage
parmi les partenaires du projet on
retrouve l'éducation nationale mais
également des acteurs locaux comme
l'émission générale d'insertion présent
dans les établissements des fondations
comme l'école de la deuxième chance et
les missions locales qui cherchent
depuis des années à se rapprocher de
l'éducation nationale fait très très
longtemps que nous avons des fiches de
liaison pour suivre les jeunes qui
viennent chez nous alors qui devraient
retourner vers l'éducation nationale
mais la difficulté est plutôt de
mutualiser les solutions et je pense que
cette ce type de plateforme va permettre
petit à petit de construire des
solutions communes partagées en
connaissant mieux les différents
dispositifs de part et d'autre on
accueille des gens qui sont en
difficulté qui ont pas toujours toute
confiance en eux parce que une grande
partie de notre travail c'est de
reconstruire cette confiance et donc il
faut être connu et après il faut être
reconnu et travailler à l'intérieur de
cette plateforme ça nous permet
d'identifier ce pour qui on sera le plus
utile et ça je pense que c'est très
concret selon l'inspection académique
d'ici la rentrée prochaine les PLA
devrait se structurer davantage avec
notamment la création d'un numéro de
téléphone unique ou encore la mise à
disposition de locaux spécifiques pour
accueillir les jeunes sur notre secteur
ce sont les CIO d'Élancourt et de
Saint-Cyr et les missions locales de
plaisir et de 50 ans qui portent le
dispositif je sais manuel Rodriguez
peut-être en conclusion quelles sont vos
espoirs et vos craintes en matière
d'emploi alors on va commencer par les
espoirs alors
le positifs elles sont aujourd'hui de
l'ordre de quelque chose qui n'est pas
encore avéré donc peut-être rester sur
des choses qui sont très très précises
d'abord il faut rappeler qu'il y a 7000
établissements sur le territoire de la
Communauté d'entreprises sur le
territoire de la Communauté
d'Agglomération ça représente 99.000
emplois on posait tout à l'heure la
question de savoir pourquoi le
territoire ne subit pas les assauts de
la crise c'est notamment parce que
derrière le substrat est relativement
important la deuxième chose c'est qu'on
peut compter sur des forces vives et les
demandeurs d'emploi en sont des vrais
compétences et il nous appartient pour
l'emploi financeur de formation mais
avec son des partenaires de faire en
sorte que la montée en compétences
puisse se faire au travers du dispositif
comme les actions de formation qu'on
promouvons mais également des actions de
formation qui permettent à des demandes
d'emploi d'être formés en emploi dans
l'entreprise et puis il y a d'autres
motifs d'espérance il y a nous allons
nous développer bientôt sur le
territoire de la Communauté
d'Agglomération pour ce public dont on
n'a pas beaucoup parlé qui existe à
hauteur de 11% sur le territoire de la
Communauté qui sont les cadres avec
l'ouverture à la rentrée prochaine d'une
agence spécialisée de plein droit pour
merci infiniment à tous les quatre
malheureusement voilà le temps vous êtes
un parti est terminé et nous on se
retrouve très vite pour une prochaine
émission consacrée à cette série sur les
40 ans de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines